Shimon Perez Israeli statesman and the
last of the founders of the State of
Israel is dead at age 93 and while many
are mourning the death of who they see
as an icon of peace this is a man who
was long a towering figure of moral
leadership others are remembering his
victims
shamone Perez made his first big mark
during the 1948 arab-israeli war he
helped secure weapons for the
paramilitary group the Hagana which
later came to form the Israeli army now
Perez would go on to have a really
illustrious career he served as a
minister of defense twice Foreign
Minister three times and even held the
offices of Transportation and Finance
Minister all of that of course in
addition to his tenure as Israel's prime
minister and president Perez also is
credited for being the architect of
Israel's nuclear program and for pushing
for secret peace talks between the
Israelis and Palestinians and it was for
his role in the Oslo peace process that
he as foreign minister would win the
Nobel Peace Prize with Israeli Prime
Minister Yitzhak Ravine and Palestinian
leader Yasser Arafat now despite the
Oslo peace process ultimately being a
failure poor his legacy has been
inseparable from it
but while Perez is celebrated in death
as he was later in his life for being a
peacemaker
for many his legacy is that of a war
criminal responsible for the death and
displacement of thousands and for
supporting criminal policies at home and
abroad in addition to his role in the
ethnic cleansing of Palestinians that
led to the creation of the State of
Israel as Minister of Defense in the
1970s Perez was key in the establishment
of Israel's illegal settlement project
settlements that he never stopped
supporting even when he was calling for
peace during that same time Perez worked
closely with the apartheid government in
South Africa claiming shared values and
even agreeing to sell at nuclear
warheads then there was a Cana massacre
in 1996 with Perez as its Prime Minister
Israel attacked a UN compound in the
south of Lebanon in the village of Cana
over 100 civilians who had sought refuge
in the compound were killed an amnesty
international investigation even
concluded that the tak was in fact
intentional ultimately Perez's legacy is
an uncomfortable contradiction he was a
man that spoke of peace while spending
his life actively working against it
you